now we're gonna get a little more
complex with these two group
disconnections let's look at an example
so we're going to think about cleaving a
bond that puts these two groups in a 1:2
relationship so we have the ether over
here on this carbon and then on this
carbon we have the O H so the carbon
numbering is telling you the
relationship of these two oxygen
containing groups let's add our
retro-synthetic arrow and name the type
of cleavage that we're going to do will
disconnect here and this is a 1/2
dioxygen disconnection now let's draw
our sentence so just splitting this bond
here are the fragments we get we talked
about oxygen naturally having a negative
polarity so let's make this our donor
synth on and this carbon here will be
our acceptor I want to introduce a
little more terminology now this is
actually a d1 synth on the negative
charge is right where the bond is going
to form so it's on that atom and this is
an acceptor synth on it's an a2 synth on
because this is one two carbons away
from where the functional group is we
can call this a 2 now we need to think
about reagents actual things we can buy
this pretty obviously can just have a
proton on here so this can come from
benzyl alcohol but how are we going to
make this in our last example we saw
putting on a leaving group so maybe we
could try that
so this synth on would be equivalent to
a reagent like this now with this
reagent the reaction will be actually
pretty tough we have an alkoxide here
but this could get deprotonated too and
this is just kind of complicated there's
actually a better reagent that we can
use if we think about this oxygen as
having lone pairs and thinking about how
it might interact with a positive charge
next to it well we might think of using
a lone pair and making a bond well that
would give us an epoxy ID hey that's
pretty great under Basic Conditions
Epoque sides adhere at the least
hindered carbon and open up quite
smoothly to give a functional group
similar to this so let's show our
forward synthesis so if we treat benzyl
alcohol with sodium hydride and then our
app oxide I've abbreviated the
cyclohexyl C hex that'll give us our
target molecule here let's call this
synthesis a and do a new example this
time with oxygen and nitrogen in a 1:2
relationship now the opening of an epoxy
with an amine is not as reliable of a
reaction and so I'm going to show you a
different way to disconnect this
molecule to introduce a new reaction
that gives the nitrogen and oxygen in
the one two relationship I'm actually
going to cleave this bond first and
capitalise on the amine forming reaction
that we just learned the reductive
amination so we can avoid any over
alkylation this disconnection actually
combines two steps if I show these as
the starting materials for it so I'm
just gonna add reduction here now I'm
going to do another functional group
inter conversion of this to show you how
this can actually come from a nitrile
now cyanide is a nucleophile that can
add in two carbonyl compounds so now
maybe the disconnection for this will
become a little bit more obvious how
would we get a carbonyl by disconnecting
this will need to cleave right here so
this the anion of cyanide so perhaps the
reagent here could be sodium cyanide
will nucleophilically adhere to this
carbon and this is the same type of
disconnection that we can get with
grignard --zz this one one carbon-carbon
disconnection let's look at a forward
synthesis for this one we'll treat our
aldehyde with sodium cyanide and we'll
have to do a workup to protonate the
alcohol now we can reduce this to get to
our amine lithium aluminum hydride
followed by a workup we'll do the job
and I've flipped the molecule over so
it'll look like this now we can perform
our reductive amination so we'll treat
with the aldehyde and then sodium
borohydride to reduce the amine that
forms here's the intermediate amine and
the sodium borohydride converts this to
our target molecule we try to be equal
opportunity to all hetero atoms here so
now let's do an example with oxygen and
sulfur in a 1:2 relationship now if we
start off with a functional group
interconversion and imagine that this
alcohol comes from a carbonyl compound
we'll open up a whole new type of
reaction to give us this 1/2
relationship now if we were to cleave on
this side of sulfur we'd have a whole
lot of functional groups to introduce
over here anyway on this piece so it
makes sense to do our disconnection to
the right of sulfur here since sulfur is
a nucleophilic atom it makes sense to
make this our donor sin thon and put our
negative charge on sulfur this will put
a positive charge on this carbon atom
now we need to come up with some
reagents that we'd use for this
transformation it makes sense that the
sulfur containing molecule comes from
the Thyle
or maybe the sodium salt of the Thyle
and to make this carbon into an acceptor
Centon well we can add a leaving group
as we did before
these alpha halo carbonyl compounds are
quite straightforward to make so this is
an excellent reagent for this reaction
we have this halide leaving group
adjacent to the carbonyl and these are
great partners for the sn2 reaction so
we can imagine reacting these in an sn2
fashion to give this and then doing a
reduction to arrive at our final target
molecule here let's look at some more
two group disconnections
all right now we're going to look at an
example where two oxygen atoms are in a
1 3 relationship this compound is a beta
hydroxy ketone and this is made by the
aldol reaction we have a carbonyl over
here and an alcohol over here the side
and the aldol that retains the carbonyl
was the side that analyzed so that means
the carbon had a negative charge on it
so we'll draw our disconnection
here we'll name this a13 dioxygen
cleavage and let's draw our sentence
here we have a d2 synth on the negative
charge is on the second carbon from this
oxygen and this is an a1 synth on with
the positive charge adjacent to the O H
now with our Epoque side we thought
about pushing electrons toward the
positive charge we're gonna do the same
thing here and if we consider this
donating these electrons down well we'll
see that this is actually equivalent to
the ketone so our synth on is equivalent
to acetone and this reaction can occur
from the condensation of two molecules
of acetone one that is een alized and
one that is not now we need to remember
the hydroxy ketones are not typically
isolated from the aldol reaction often
we treat these with acid or base and
they undergo dehydration quite readily
and a lot of the times these reactions
are under acidic or basic conditions and
so this is what you I salute you
actually don't get this so the one three
relationship of two oxygens might not be
as obvious here but would just have to
remember this one when we see in a known
so this conjugated double bond with a
carbonyl we have to know that this is a
great compound to form via the aldol
reaction in fact this disconnection is
so common often this is not shown and
will abbreviate by cleaving this bond in
half
writing alpha beta over the arrow and
showing our starting materials let's
look at an example when oxygen and
nitrogen are in a 1:3 relationship we
have this compound this these R groups
could be anything we have two different
R groups on here and just like last time
we're going to use a nitrile to
introduce this amine but we're gonna do
it in a different way so the first thing
that we'll do here is a functional group
interconversion to go to the nitrile now
nitriles like carbonyl compounds can
analyze this occurs adjacent to the
cyano group
and is very favorable due to resonance
so we can draw a disconnection right
here bearing in mind that the nitrile
analyzes readily this will be our donor
synth on and let's draw what our
acceptor is boy and this looks a lot
like what we had here this a1 acceptor
right here so we can envision this
coming from the aldehyde so for our
forward synthesis which I'll just talk
through in the interest of time we'll
take this nitrile without the negative
charge treat it with an appropriate base
and form this we can then add it to this
aldehyde and work it up to get this
molecule let's look at something with
oxygen and sulphur in a 1:3 relationship
to talk about one more really important
reaction as I mentioned at the beginning
it's often good to cleave next to a
hetero atom and if we cleaved over here
we'd have a lot of functional groups on
this side of the molecule so it makes
sense to cleave right here on the right
hand side of sulphur so that we can join
two pieces with different functionality
sulfur is naturally a nucleophile so
this is an appropriate donor Centon and
our acceptor will look like this now
introducing a leaving group at this
position isn't the easiest thing with a
carbonyl compound remember we like to
add them right here
adjacent to the carbonyl because that's
an easy reaction alpha halogenation but
here we would need a beta halogen so
actually we can use a different compound
to approach this when an enone like this
encounters a soft nucleophile something
with a negative charge that's really
spread out and polarizable well the
addition occurs at this carbon in a 1 4
or michael addition fashion so for our
forward synthesis we can treat this in
own with perhaps the sodium salt of the
parent Thyle followed by a workup to get
our proton back I almost feel like I
don't know where to stop with this video
we could just look at so many more
disconnections and different
relationships of functional groups
there is one more that I want to point
out ending with this feels kind of funny
to just not mention it so let me just
show you one forward example to show you
how we can get a 1:5 dioxygen
relationship in a molecule with a
reaction that's a Michael addition so
I'm not going to show this retro
synthetically but I just want to point
out this in the molecule and then maybe
I'll break the bond at the end if we
treat this with an enolate so let's do
the enolate of diethyl malonate we'll
get a conjugate addition and I'm
abbreviating this will just add a proton
somewhere in here let's show the product
that we get from this overall process so
in one single step we've created a one
two three four five carbon relationship
of these two functional groups but when
you see this relationship it might not
be so obvious because we have to
remember that these esters undergo
hydrolysis and decarboxylation quite
readily so if we treat this compound
with acid and heat we'll get this
product and our groups are still in the
one five relationship but it's not quite
so obvious that it came from this great
enol eight here that's really stabilized
and easy to form but this is a great way
to form that one five relationship so
for this example our retro-synthetic
disconnection would be right here KP
here if you learn something give me a
thumbs up on the way out and for more
chemistry subscribe to my channel